the Shaolin monks of China are an
ancient order surrounded in mystery they
spend their lives learning kung fu and
Buddhist philosophy
you can choose two parts of my charts or
choose to pray but I just combined both
together I chose the worst way after
defecting from Communist China one
Shaolin monk found himself living in New
York training some unique clients
ranging from movie stars to hip-hop
artists my name is Sheree I mean I'm the
founder and abbot of USA Shaolin Temple
I was training at a park first summer
training said you want to teach who
owned study and I said no problem I'm
pure talk to people you know spreading
the word
algebraically I have students come from
everywhere from our own world this come
here just for one week sometimes a month
it just come here to study as Xian
Ming's popularity grew his teachings
began attracting the attention of one of
New York's most famous hip-hop artists
the Shifu has spent years training with
RZA from wu-tang clan even going so far
as to appear in the music video for
Shaolin Temple the last period when atop
a prayer of faith for wu-tang clan they
loved Chinese culture they have loved my
charts but chien-ming strongly believes
that the benefits of Shaolin can be
adapted for any individual anybody can
get it benefited because different kind
of styles for different people never old
never young never hope I'm never sure
run run
I want to reach as many people as
possible
you made precious life time because my
ultimate goal
you